by the way let's uh draw a distinction
between control and mechanics
like how how can how would you define
each yep
i mean i think part of the point is that
we shouldn't draw a line
as as as clearly as we tend to but
the you know on a robot we have motors
and we have
the links of the robot let's say if the
motors are turned off
the robot has some passive dynamics okay
gravity does the work you can put
springs i would call that mechanics
right if we have springs and dampers
which our muscles are springs and
dampers and tendons
um but then you have something that's
doing active work putting energy in
your motor is on the robot the
controller's job is to
send commands to the motor that add new
energy into the system
right so the mechanics and control
interplay somewhere the divide is around
you know did you decide to send some
commands to your motor or did you just
leave the motors off and let them do
their work
would you say is most of nature
on the dynamic side or the control side
so like if you look at biological
systems if
you know we're living in a pandemic now
like do you think a virus is a
do you think it's a dynamic system or um
or is there a lot of control
intelligence i think it's both but i
think we
maybe have underestimated how important
the dynamics are
right i mean even our bodies
the mechanics of our bodies certainly
with exercise they evolved but
so i actually i lost a finger in early
2000's
and it's my fifth metacarpal
it turns out you use that a lot in ways
you don't expect when you're opening
jars
even when i'm just walking around if i
bump it on something
there's a bone there that was used to
taking
contact my fourth metacarpal wasn't used
to taking contact it used to hurt
it still does a little bit but actually
my bone has remodeled
right get the over the last over a
couple years
the geometry the mechanics of that bone
change to address the new circumstances
so the idea that somehow
it's only our brain that's adapting or
evolving is not right
you